weiße zelte mit un hcr logo und jeder
menge stacheldraht
hier lebt die ja naja es ist genau das
camp im dass sie und ihre familie nicht
wollten
noch gestern stand die achtjährige mit
ihren eltern in einer langen schlange
zusammen mit tausenden flüchtlingen
es gibt einige blonder afghanen auf
lesbos doch so hell wie diana ist keiner
das warten in der prallen brennenden
sonne ist die reinste tortur für ihre
haut noch am vortag konnte sie schutz
vor der sonne im notdürftig errichteten
wilden camps suchen
doch das lager wurde geräumt der ort auf
einem beton dach wo dianas aus
bambusstöcken gebaute hütte stand ist
leer
wie die meisten der 13.000 obdachlos
gewordenen menschen wollte dianas
familien nicht ins neue un hcr camp es
sei ein leben wie im gefängnis
8000 plätze direkt am meer zwischen
stacheldraht doch nur hier haben diana
und ihre eltern mohammad unter schema
überhaupt eine chance aus europäische
festland zu gelangen
nur hier werden die asyl befragungen der
behörden weiter geführt
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren